it says heading to lower Manhattan the
courthouse seems so surreal he says wow
they're going to arrest me you can't
believe this is happening in America and
then Maga make America great again so
Donald Trump
um apparently sending that out from his
car on the way to the to the courthouse
and there there are just following up
with what you were saying about Michael
Cohen and so forth there are legal
experts who say that that well they're
looking fairly skeptically at this
indictment
get better
once looked at the indictment but
everyone's talking about it and the
assumption is is that because Michael
Cohen testified that we know that it's
about the hush money and so if it's
about the hush money it's about Michael
Cohen I mean Stormy Daniels may be
testifying but Stormy Daniels as far as
I know didn't have a discussion with
Trump about the hush money it was
through lawyers and one of those lawyers
was Michael Cohen and so it at the end
of the day
um this case rises in Falls potentially
with Michael Cohen and again I heard one
of your guests saying even the average
Joe could basically come in and
cross-examine him I I think he's right I
mean by the way you could use everything
he said on every News Channel before and
after to show how biased he is in
regards to Trump is that the ideal
prosecution witness no and again that's
why we wonder what the other evidence is
to support his claims
yeah and we'll see that hopefully in due
course I mean there was another former
someone reminded me yesterday another
Democrat in this occasion Canada John
Edwards who was accused of violating
campaign Finance laws
um using payments to cover up an affair
and you know in his case jurors
acquitted him of one charge and then
couldn't make their mind up on others
um so some sort of similarity being
drawn there by one of Donald Trump's uh
supporters
right it
is what happened with John Edwards it's
in because one of the things that is
being said is is this going to open the
floodgates uh keep in mind let's imagine
if the D.A in the future is a republican
are we going to start to see Democratic
former presidents
um you know indicted and charged with
crimes that one would not have expected
for them to be charged with
um in the view that this is just a
political move
um again I I don't know
um but John Edwards is something that
they're looking at saying look they
tried but John Edwards they failed
they're going to fail again